أو تسبب هذا الانفجار في مقتل أحد
أبرز المدونين العسكريين المؤيدين للحرب في روسيا الذين
نشروا تحت اسم فلاد
لنتاتاسكي ، حيث جمع أكثر من نصف
مليون متابع على
قناته البرقية المؤيدة للحرب والتي كان
معروفًا عنها بحماس شديد
على أوكرانيا  سوف نقتل كل شخص سنقوم
بسرقة كل شخص سنشق طريقنا
وبالطبع مثل
المدونين العسكريين الروس البارزين الآخرين الذين ينتقدون جوانب تتعلق
بك ، تعرف كيف تخاض الحرب في أوكرانيا ،
كان تاتاسكي
المتحدث الضيف في تجمع مؤيد للحرب في
مقهى سانت بطرسبرغ عندما
وقع الانفجار في المكان ، وتحدث شهود عيان
عن كيفية حدوثه بعد
وقت قصير من تقديمه له تمثالًا صغيرًا ،
لكن في صندوق هدايا ، قالت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية نقلاً عن
مصادر رسمية إن
عبوة ناسفة ربما كانت مخبأة داخل
التمثال.  إنكار
المسؤولية من أوكرانيا مع
المستشار الرئاسي هناك
ووصفها بأنها أشبه
بنزاع روسي داخلي ، لكن تارتارسكي بالطبع
هو ثاني
ناشط روسي مؤيد للحرب يتم استهدافه
وقتله في روسيا منذ غزوها
لأوكرانيا العام الماضي في أغسطس.
قُتل مواطن بارز هنا في
انفجار سيارة مفخخة خارج موسكو. اتهم المسؤولون الروس في
ذلك الوقت المخربين الأوكرانيين بالهجوم
أوكرانيا تصر على أنها
لا علاقة لها به.